You know, I can see how Destiny lying about Willie M could be
wrong, but I just find it really hard to feel any sympathy for
him when he's such a disgusting inbred rodent. >> I just
say if you're working in a factory, you don't have the skills
to go >> like like a factory that like makes drones of
kids or like child molest. >> Yeah. You're the you're the
guy who pulls Yeah. You're you're just working at Awitz and you're
pulling the lever on >> gas.
It's a job. It's a job. It's a living. Okay. [music]
>> Dioro is still mad at everybody. Have you seen this?
That he's like going hard on everybody today. >> Oh, Dioro.
>> Yeah, Dioro. He's like tweeting a bunch >> Um,
I've seen >> responding to everybody. >> I I read
his Discord messages, but I haven't read tweets. >> Let
me go find the uh the lumpy Willy. Lumpy Willie totally a logging
Nicholas Dioro. Very curious that Aiden's top guy is a logging
Nicholas Dioro this hard yet Nicholas thinks he's friends with
Just it's just strange to me.
Seems like Nicholas Yori regrets helping out his ex-lover irrational
Chad during his time of need. We will continue to monitor the
situation closely.
Should have left him to rot with the DG guys clawing at him.
Was this even that bad? I think most of like Destiny's orbit
liked Chud when he left. I don't think most of them had a problem
with him. I would say it's like like people were taking Destiny's
side in a fight, but with the way Chud like cut off and wasn't
going to talk about Destiny anymore, I don't think anybody was
going after him. >> I think this is like really blowing
up what's happening there. You know, these years were just tearing
each other apart. I don't what that was, where this has come
from. What's going on there? He got some for like the
stuff that leaked around the ML article. I think Molina stuff
and then
Lawrence stuff and something something else. >> That's
kind of objectively on counterpoints. That's kind of objectively
on >> Yeah, that is objectively on counter, but Chud got
the most of the bane for it. Um,
but yeah, I don't really this narrative that oh Chud's career
was struggling or stream was struggling because DGG guys hated
him that time. I don't know where that's come from. I don't remember
that at all. I was >> I'm sure I'm sure that when he was
like I'm explicitly cutting out that Destiny section of content.
I'm sure his viewership dropped because he would have had DJs
who would watch him and want him to cover that stuff. And by
not >> average viewership. Yeah. Yeah. I don't think he
ever dwindled off of it, but he definitely, you know, you don't
get those same peaks of everyone coming in if you're not willing
to engage with that with that content when you're in that position,
right? >> Yeah, exactly. So, I I can totally understand
where that's coming from and how he messaged Nicholas and Nicholas
was like going and like joining up and
DG was sad he left. Well, I don't think he like explicitly left.
it was like a drifting apart and then maybe
I I feel like after a while he was like, "Okay, I'm not going
to cover the Destiny stuff anymore." And he explained that it
wasn't to do with Destiny, although I don't think that's true
necessarily entirely. I think it was like um both. He thought
it was about the audience, the audience coming in and being like,
"You should cover this right now." Right? You see a bunch of
people falling to this right now, by the way. Bunch of people
who like weren't associated with Destiny. And then it's like
you have a whole bunch of people in your audience who are like,
"You should cover this. You should cover this. You should cover
this. you should cover this. And eventually people just kind
of give into >> Yeah, I agree. Hutch is like a degenerate
subhuman ape. I agree. >> I didn't watch that today. I
will probably watch that today actually. The Hutch Pisco conversation.
I think that's actually um >> I saw bits of it, but it
was quite boring from what I saw.
>> Well, I hope it's not boring. Hope it's good. Okay.
Apparently, Nick is crashing out in his little hug box rather
than talk his live total behavior. Hold on. Uh 300 p.m. Watch
any Chud debate. It's slow, boring. He reads chat and then awkwardly
starts yelling to try and make it more entertaining or plays
contrarian because they weren't enjoying it. Hardly even a person.
It's just chronic chat slave content.
What? He could have said this at any point in the last couple
weeks, but he is like it doesn't require the Tom video being
out for him to say this, but he just said it when Chud goes on
holiday so Chud can't talk to you on his stream. This guy's completely
insensitive about what people are saying about him. >> I
think it's really funny.
Like I don't know in what way the
the debate stuff he did or the well he said I guess he covers
both basises right or both bases. He either tries to yell to
make it more entertaining or plays could train because they weren't
enjoying it. It's like oh maybe this isn't covering both bases
but it's like the uh the ice shooting. I'm pretty sure that him
pretty badly covering that and sticking to his guns on it. I
think I think it kind of him I don't I don't know. I'd say Chud
is less like that than most influencers. Chud has a YouTube chat.
Well, Chud has like a YouTube chat. I feel like Chud has multiple
influences pulling on him in different directions. So, he gets
to be like centered, right? >> He's got like the spicy
chat people who push him in a direction, but he's also got like
a broader audience that are more like the they kind of like the
racist humor. They're more right-wing who push him in the other
direction, right? So, I think he gets to get stabilized by that
whereas Nick just has, you know, one audience pulling him in
the orbit Ethan Klein's ball sack direction. And I don't know
what else goes on there. It's chronic chat slave content is very
interesting to me. Just that comment is like actually annoying
to hear. >> It's got as opposed to chronic slave content
which Nick makes. >> Speaking of
might check uh might check out that panel later.
Ethan Klein versus Benny Johnson. Let's go. Ch is pretty good
at sticking to his principles. He is a he has a pretty diverse
audience. I think so. Chud's just funny. That's why he has an
audience. Like at the end of the day, it's not about principles.
It's just I think he's just funny. That's why he has an audience.
I think that's why he can like flip back and forth. Like he could
take a more right-wing position and not lose his audience at
all.
You're funny, you could do it. If you're funny, they let you
do anything. Okay. I feel like Nick is partially jealous Chud
can have more fun with his content and not stick to the same
two or three topics every day. Uh maybe. I think like I've watched
Nicholas's stream. It's obviously not as good as Chud's. I think
it's just pretty obviously like cheerleader content, which is
fine. You can do that, but I do think if that well ever runs
dry, he would be in quite a bit of trouble. Personally, maybe
not. Maybe he could pivot to something else. That's how I feel
about it. That's that's my diagnosis. He's He's like funny, but
I don't get that from
you like Ethan Klein cheerleader >> I
Well, I'm saying it's fine as in like whatever you make your
money. I like it's basically working in a factory. I just say
if you're working in a factory, you don't have the skills to
go >> like like a factory that like makes drones of kids
or like child molest. >> Yeah. You're the you're the guy
who pulls Yeah. You're you're just working at Awitz and you're
pulling the lever on
job. It's a job. It's a living. Okay. Guy's got to feed his family.
What is he supposed to do? Just not feed his
>> That's what I thought. That's remaining priv Oh, sorry.
Count how many friends this guy has from before we met him.
That's remaining private because I'm not sharing anything that's
not public. Wait, I think Chud does have friends. I thought Chud
basically moved on
Maybe I'm wrong. I I'm behind the scenes.
The people I know who dislike Chud or who had problems with Chud
when he was leaving,
who were his friends before, I think
probably in some ways understand they were manipulated.
Okay,
I'm just being real because I know there was like a fight between
um basically if you guys don't know about this, there was a fight
between Destiny and Chud where Destiny and a bunch of people
around Destiny were trying to pressure Chud to fire his editor.
If if you don't know this, I think there's like a year and a
half period where like four different people all were like, "Chud,
you have to fire your editor. Chud, you have to fire your editor."
Am I wrong on that? It would be
>> uh Doobie. Doobie definitely said it. Sunday said it.
Destiny said it. Um,
and yeah. Okay. So, there's a lot of people who are like, "Chud,
you have to fire your editor. Chud, you have to fire your editor."
And some of the arguments were like good as in some of the arguments
were valid. I think >> like some allegation
>> not that one. Although also, yes. The one that like
DK made a comment that was like sort of unprofessional on the
Chudlogic account. I was like, "Okay, that's like valid. That's
bad or whatever." Wicked Supreme said it. Um, yeah. Sup. Well,
I was saying that's along with the Destiny thing, right? That
I think it was something about Molina. I forget.
And I think, you know, Destiny played victim a lot on that stuff
and made a lot of people dislike Chud for defending his editor
as as one does,
right? But I I think a lot of those people weren't necessarily
not friends with Chud. They were like, "Okay, if you're going
to stand by this guy, we're not going to hang out with you."
Which sucks, but I don't think any of them hated him. And I think
probably in retrospect a lot of them can identify that that's
just like um
it's just stupid. Let's see.
DK was talking well no DK was sorry DK was talking about Lauren
Southern but I'm saying that I think it was comments on Molina
that they said were the unprofessional thing. That might not
have been the YouTube comment. I I know what I was told was there
was a private like VC somewhere. not private, but a VC somewhere
where DK and his girlfriend were in that VC and apparently were
talking about like
this what I heard and by the way totally unsubstantiated but
this is like what behind the scenes Destiny's like side was really
signaling about was they were talking about how funny it was
going to be when Molina killed herself and nobody cared because
like even if she named Destiny this note or some like this like
it wouldn't matter like people were going to defend that guy
anyway which you know sounds kind of accurate to me but they
like it basically got spun as they for laughing at the idea that
Molina would kill herself or something. Right.
That's what I heard behind the scenes. I don't know if you ever
heard anything. I think I discussed this once with you on
>> Yeah. I I never heard anything about that from anyone
other than you
>> I said I said send me a recording of this. I no recording
was produced so I don't know if somebody was there and they said
it and then it was one of those things where it's being This
is why I get annoyed. You would have sweeped that. You're just
wrong. I literally talked about how I thought DK got a raw deal
um openly when I was still a part of Destiny's community that
he was like treated unfairly. That that wasn't necessarily the
case that I heard both sides of that story. It's totally
but um in fact, hold on. Um
one guy me take a break for a bit. Boom. All right. So,
what where was I going with this
Oh, I thought Yeah, I got a raw deal. Yeah, I lost my train of
thought. That's fine. Um Oh, yeah. People just broadly didn't
dislike Chud at the end of that. It was like mostly around DK.
Oh, right. No, no, no. Hold on. There's no substantiation to
it and I think I don't know. I think broadly
they use this tactic a lot. I feel like there are people who
use this tactic a lot where they'll say something happened behind
the scenes and then they'll tell people about it, right? Like
I watched this tactic be used on me where apparently, you know,
behind the scenes Destiny can go to somebody and say like I'm
doxing people or my community is doxing people, provide no proof,
right? And then I'll have people who will amplify that message.
Like counterpoints will basically, you know, I think he started
eventually going to well, you know, allegedly
or something, but people will just amplify that. They'll have
no substantiation behind that at all. >> Yeah. It's just
it's quite annoying as a
And anyway, that's why people think um I guess Chud is persona
on Grata. It let him left him to rot with the DGG guys clawing
at him. Don't believe that
Oh, this was before and it's in a different order. So, actually
this is from earlier.
Sakes. Lumpy Will, you're going up. You're uploading the wrong
order. Okay. Was it about the daily drama
drama channels? This is Nicholas talking about Chud's original
tweeters, original messages at Spicy Chat. It was about me. This
is Chud complaining at Spicy Chat that people were going to sweep.
The big sweep was going to be in. Um, then his VOD came out.
He made a tweet that was the exact same arguments verbatim from
the segment about me, but broad enough to give him plausible
deniability. He'd been taking shots for a while. It's all for
content. The plan is say something debate Nick on my stream.
He's like a street bum throwing rocks and expecting quarters
in return.
I mean, yeah, that's a good way to describe Chud stream.
That's that's the branding. Wait, what are you talking about,
Nick? Because I'm definitely not talking about that spicy live
VC.
I was in that spicy live VC. I was definitely not talking about
that spicy live VC. The one you're talking about, I'm not talking
about that. This happened before that.
The thing I'm talking about,
Hold on.
what is this?
I just got to send a tweet. Hold on. Let me see this. Let me
see this.
Nicholas. Oh, I see. I see. I didn't spell it right. Fortunately,
blocked. Delusional takes. Turkey Tom dropped a 41minute response
video to his allegations on his main YouTube channel. He docks
as his accuser in this video when it wasn't necessarily uh when
it wasn't necessary whatsoever to deny the allegations against
him. It was purely out of spite. That's just 100% true. Like
the only argument against this by the way from anybody
um the only argument against this in my opinion is
what it's well she deserved it. It's not even an argument against
it. It's a justification for doing it right.
Why is Nick calling this delusional? I have no idea.
Let's say you let's see if they say anything cuz he's a pig.
Uh well well
I I don't get how we're pretending that that didn't happen. It's
very goofy. Hold on. Let me throw some music back on
I'm going to check Nick's replies because I I I feel like Nick's
been replying to a lot of people recently. Check it out.
Oh, hellbent in the comments. Uh oh.
Uh, I didn't help I didn't help but think or sorry, I can't help
but think that if Turkey Tom was a hefty trans character with
a deep voice, the commentary community would be licking their
lips the and catching the first frame home to cover it.
This tweet is about sensitive society if anyone was wondering.
And if he wants to call into my show to chat about this random
I made up about him just now, you'd be I'd be happy to know.
Or sorry, no, I'd be happy to chat,
dude.
He's
just going to keep going off like this. It's very funny.
>> That's a Willy M line.
>> What's that? I just woke up. What did I >> No,
the um
>> Oh, you're just making [__] up about me
and demanding I go on your stream.
>> no one's saying that.
I and what I remember what he said about he he the thing he said
that about was me saying he coordinated with Aerodite to make
that video and then I was just like totally proven right like
two months later. >> What do you mean proven right? You
knew you were right. You were totally >> Yeah, I knew I
was right, but but people accused me of lying and uh >> Oh,
I see. I was proven right.
>> I I don't know why he denied that.
I actually I have no idea. Like there's a lot of people who just
do that on the >> He's immally
can't imagine.
And it's like maybe some failing on my part just like openly
lying directly about something. Do you know what I mean? Like
like basically knowing I'm lying and just saying the thing like
in in a substantial context. Do you know what I mean? Like uh
like you're trying to argue with somebody in on Twitter about
the the what would she say? like the integrity of your work and
you just openly lie about something you know you could be proven
wrong on
I it just doesn't even strike me to attempt it very goofy
I just woke up what did I do glad you asked you swept like a
your arguments were dog which is even worse on a related note
if there have been infinite cases where a man gets dropped over
false allegations how come you and legal mindset are only able
to reference Johnny Depp I didn't know all that
okay all right Nicholas knows Chud was going away so that's why
he's going off publicly right now
>> yep, yep, yep, yep. >> That's going to be part
of it,
but I feel like he would try to get his he would try to get his
jabs in here either way. He just wouldn't be this he wouldn't
be this extra, right? He wouldn't be posting it constantly. I
do think he'd try to get his jabs in back trying to be like,
I was I knew Tom was innocent and that's why I wasn't going to
talk about it
personally. This also applies to your pals, Auggie, child, etc.
and yourself. Is that like Queman or Chud? I can't tell. I given
how you covered the Liam drama, but sure. Directed at one [__]
I didn't farm or cover trans lyrics. Nick versus Chud. Let's
go. You guys are just worthless.
Wow.
Oh, I like this tweet. You see this tweet? I thought we learned
eight years ago that it's based to not cover allegations until
both sides responded.
Do you know what the best part about this tweet is? Queenman,
>> is he by the tweet? He's a slack Jordan in bread. >> Uh,
one he got by Destiny a quote tweet. No, it's that he defends
the idea that so long as somebody doesn't respond, he's not going
to cover like the the hack to get around Willie Mack covering
any of your terrible allegations is to never respond. And he
like actually doubles down on how that is the case. >> Just
just get around. Don't respond. Willie Mack can never cover it.
>> He can't cover it. He literally can't. He's It's the
loophole. Okay. Just don't ever respond and Willie Mack will
not talk about it. Amazing stuff.
Uh, somebody says, "So, two women accused Hassan of sexual misconduct
as well as extremely embarrassing personal life details. You
and Nick will not cover it all even if he stays completely silent."
Yeah, obviously true. And he's like, "No, I will stay silent.
Look, look, I Hassan had the brothel thing and I never covered
it." Although Hassan said the brothel thing was he alleged it
so or sorry, he um responded to it. >> Responded to that.
Why can't you cover that? What's >> Yeah, it's he's >> This
guy is so >> It's very rough. Okay. Did Willie cover TechOne
at all? Probably not. Willie Willie can only cover stuff like
two months after it happened. So, he's he's on a delay. Okay.
He He couldn't have possibly covered the Tetoone yet. Willie
is on a two-month delay for any videos. Like, they come out way
maybe a onemon delay. I'll give him a one-mon delay. Okay. You
can cover it as long as you cover the response refuting it, too.
What's wrong with that? Yeah, exactly. He's waiting for Destiny's
verdict. Destiny's verdict doesn't change anything. That's the
funny thing.
Like that's hold on. Um that's the other thing about Desi's tweet
there that we're referring to,
right?
Like the allegation. So this is whether or not Destiny can be
held civily liable for the things he did. Destiny admitted to
the things he did. Nobody questions the things he did. It's just
about whether or not he could be held civily liable and pay penalties
to the person he wronged. That's what the entire civil case is
about. Right. Also,
Destiny did respond to Willie. No. Was Willie Mack covering it
before Destiny
Not not in a video at least, right?
I guess not.
>> So, like this doesn't even apply. It's just very funny.
It's like a lot of people just, you know, coping in all different
directions right now. >> Oh, yeah. But um no
uh Willie Mac
used Destiny's lies against me. So it's funny when Destiny lies
against him and I will laugh at him.
>> that is him getting that's him. >> Would you say
Would you say it's like hard for you to feel empathy for Willie
Mack right now? >> It is. It is.
>> Yeah. It's like very difficult. You You can't see You
won't get any sympathy from me. It's wrong, but you won't get
No, no, this is better. Wait, this is exactly how
phrased. >> You know, I can see how Destiny lying about
Will M could be wrong, but I just find it really hard to feel
any sympathy for him when he's such a disgusting imbred rodent.
Yeah. Yeah, I get it. I can feel it.
That's he was giving him whole exclusive interviews where Willie
was incredibly charitable, incredibly like kind to him, right?
And essentially, dude, somebody makes a comment here somewhere
about how Willie um Oh, it's this person. It's this. It's the
Oh, it's like this
This person comments on like, "Oh, you said Destiny's DMs were
off the record." It's like, okay, I'm pretty sure we can all
agree that if you admit to keeping child in my DMs, I think that
goes for everybody. That goes for influencers. That goes for
every single person on the planet. If someone's telling you they're
retaining child that it's not off the record anymore, okay? That's
like a required reporting thing that most people would just adhere
to. Naturally, most people are like, "Hey, I don't like I don't
like people who keep child. I just I don't like that. That's
not very cool to me.
Not a fan." Anyway, found out today that um Elijah Schaefer apparently
raped Lauren Southern too. You know about this Queenman?
>> Is that three now? Paul Joseph Watson, Andrew Tate,
and Elijah Schaefer. other women. But with Lauren Southern, they
just had some like weird drunk text or
>> They definitely No, I thought he gave her like
>> Yeah, I think they had like Well, I don't know if she
actually slept with him. I think they they had like some date
and I think she didn't sleep with him in the end >> and
he was like mad about it and crashed out in texts or some like
WhatsApp >> Very interesting.
>> That any lumpy Willie updates? We do have lumpy Willy
updates. Hold on.
Lumpy Willie throwing up more tweets here that we can watch.
The premier Nicholas Yoro Alog right now. Okay.
Oh, hold on. Nicholas Doro is a fat rat. This is what Doryo thinks
is an attempt to dox a simple mention that he had a girlfriend.
So, it's obviously a little bit more than this.
Backs adds on today. He brought his girlfriend to VidCon drama
to VidCon drama community parties and just expected everyone
to keep her >> Yes. Yes. Yes. Bo Black. I had multiple
people tell me about his fat their words. I never saw her girlfriend.
Thank god I never mentioned her online or I guess I would have
been doxed. Oh boy. >> Oh my god.
>> I mean
thank you Josh.
>> Listen listen listen.
I feel like
this didn't have to be leaked, right? We all >> we all
knew this deep down. It's like nice friend. He's got some pork
a [__] girlfriend. Come on. You knew when he brought
a girl. Obviously, it was true. But >> yeah, you knew when
he brought a girl, it was like, okay,
>> exactly. Fat people, you know, stick with fat people.
That's the way it should be. >> When you're When you're
that big, I don't think you you don't escape. Okay.
It's It's rough. Is this the same girl from the old Tonka clips
where Nick was crying about her? By the way, I knew these clips
existed. I knew these clips existed. You see them now? >> This
is what I was talking about. Yeah, I've seen this before.
>> Oh, well, I'm pretty sure they talk about how it's like
a little friend from before, right? >> Yeah. I just don't
remember any of the details of what they say in the clips, but
I've seen him before.
>> Yeah, I that's what I I could have sworn I remembered
this yesterday. I'm like, dude, somebody tell me what I'm talking
about. People went and found them.
You guys talking about the um the Guam pairing, the Nicholas
Yoro Guam pairing, the H3 orbit power couple,
Jupiter and Saturn. Some are saying, "Okay, let's go. Let's watch
it." Well, I I forget where these clips are. I will find them
eventually. Okay, we will find them eventually.
Where was I? I think I was going through Nicholas's replies to
see what exactly is going on here.
>> I'm sending you something.
>> I want to go live and cover basically the Elijah Schaefer
stuff and then probably H3, but yeah. Okay.
said, "Max has problems, man." It's funny, but
>> got some issues. Got some issues.
>> Nick Nick is like deep in the replies in like everywhere
today. It's actually crazy. Hold on.
See here. It's 11:00 a.m. and I'm starting to fear that the great
sweep has begun. Let's just be real. If this was anyone like
Destiny/ Assassan/ Ethan, you would have posted within the hour.
It's okay to defend your friend, but just own it. If this was
a trans person with their hair falling out, Chud would have been
live live touching tips. Damn.
Wow. See here,
lol. Who's this? Is this the person he's talking to or something?
Somebody liked the post. Go full score and drop everything you
have left. Drop the full messages. Doc Zoro's girlfriend. There's
nothing blah blah blah blah blah. Is this the person he's talking
to?
Oh, he's just complaining about this the whole way. Okay. She
has time to deny reality but not to respond to Tom and dox anyone.
Wait, this is true though. She didn't dox anybody. That That
is true. Unless I missed this. Did she also dox this person now?
I could have I could have sworn that he didn't uh or she didn't
dox this person. Oh, why is he posting? Dude,
uh he did just I did just pull that up, didn't I?
Yeah, it is technically that is technically what was there. God
damn it.
Okay, Kiwi Farms tried to help her off the ledge, by the way.
Additional context, I did get to VidCon Girl first, but she already
realized what Sacramento planned to do with that information
and cut contact.
Oh, cool. Wait, if you got there first, then how did you realize?
Or how did she realize? I got there first, but she already realized
what Sacramento planned to do. Okay, I think everyone in the
stream segment got it, but I guess I needed an additional Oh,
this is his response to us from last night, right? Like, I guess
I guess everyone in the stream got it. No, they didn't get it,
Nick. They they will literally just clap along like seals for
you. No matter what you say, they didn't get it. You said it
happened, and so they went, "Oh, yeah, it happened." And now
you're obviously realizing that there wasn't enough context there
to show that she was trying to dox your girlfriend, right? That
it was ambiguous. And so, you had to add this stuff. I guess
everybody on the stream got it. No, they just you said it was
true, so they believe you. So they're just Jesus. Okay, lol.
And then he posts this. Cool. Okay,
one more lumpy Willy tweet. One more to go, guys.
Where was this? Where do I have Where did I have the lumpy Willy
tweets at? I got to close some tabs,
Oh, show it on stream. Sure. So, what was the contention last
night? The contention last night was basically when you read
the messages that he was trying to show were proof. It's like
this
Uh I think Anam Vid Girl would know who Nicador's girlfriend
is. I wish Anam vid girl would come here to spill uh Anam VidCon
girl would come here to spill everything. Yeah, I don't know
who it is. She does. She told me the girl was apparently a long-term
girlfriend he's known since elementary school. I asked her who
she is just now.
Um and then he she talks about reaching out to somebody else.
No, VidCon girl hasn't responded. Maybe Tom or Nick got to her
and threatened her or something. Wouldn't be surprised.
Really enjoying my 5 seconds of internet clout by posting about
my insane abusive ex on Kiwi Farm. Somebody accused her of like
looking to docs, right? And then this one is
the same one from before. Yeah, this she posted the same image
twice. Those are both the same image. Okay. And then she says
she didn't dox anybody. But these were the ones that you needed
to actually show it, right? was somebody saying like, um, you
should actually fully dox these people. And then she actually
responds, I don't know if you've noticed, but I've been going
for gorilla mode. Oh, wait. This isn't even enough here, is it?
No, it is. It is. It is. Okay. So, she said, I don't know if
you know this, but I' I'm going gorilla mode on Tom since I have
hard proof of he was cheating on me and his friends were clearly
all complicit in his degenerate freak behaviors. So, at this
point, I don't really care. Sorry, Josh. I know you're probably
mad at me, right? Oh, there's there's a little bit more here
as well. There's actually two more that you need as well that
talk about
that makes it pretty clear that she w is actually looking to
dox this person. Oh, maybe showed it after stream. The message
that actually verifies what he's claiming. He did not show it
on stream. He went back and edited in the clip with the correct
screenshot at the end of the segment he uploaded talking about
Turkey Tom's response. Oh, did he really? Hold
Let's check that out. I didn't know that. Nicholas Dioro, >> this
is such an awesome hack, dude. You You make an argument. Don't
present the evidence that proves it and then call everyone for
not getting it and then unveil the evidence afterwards. That's
such a pro. I need I need to take this
>> Yeah. It's it's like I think by the way if if that weren't
the case like if we if we let's say um he had shown the evidence
correctly, you know, he'd be tweeting about us today, right?
You know that the only reason like he was so excited he was salivating.
He was in the chat. He was in the chat knowing that he could
like pull this out, that he like had a good idea
and he was like, "You guys can't possibly win this." And I'm
like, "Okay." I mean, I literally saw the evidence that you presented,
it wasn't very good, like it didn't prove anything, right?
And I know for a fact if if there had been stuff there, if he
had actually posted all of it or covered it correctly, he would
be crowing about it
I think that's why he says last night, if I remember correctly,
last night he says something along the lines of,
can I filter by user on Dorio Rodeo?
>> Yeah. Yeah, you can.
>> It's a pretty cool website. It's pretty cool website.
>> Nicholas Dioro. What? Oh, it's over here. Okay. Okay,
I see.
Oh, I can't I can't resize. Okay, I guess so.
So, he's talking about us last night. Let's see. Because he says
something
six hours ago.
It's not last night. This is this afternoon. Last night he was
talking about us and talking about how he didn't expect Oh, yeah.
Right here.
Uh, actually cool. They conceded. Lol. Let's go to this. >> He
said, did he say that? He said actually cool they conceded.
>> That's what he said. Yeah. >> Wow. That That's
so sweet. That's so sweet. Wait, why is this locked?
Person who made the site. Why is it locked? Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. Here we go. Actually, cool. They conceded full and
lied about Queen of Jtock. Yes, it's true. Cost bubbles. Thank
you.
Did not demonstrate proof. I'm just looking for where he started
talking about this. Who's he responding to here? Actually, cool.
They conceded. Lol.
I expected that.
Responding to Oh, yeah. still saying that they jumped to call
you a liar about it.
Wait, hold on. I I can't stress enough that like the calling
him a liar was based on the me the stuff he posted as evidence
for saying this person was trying to dox the his friend, >> right?
It's like using that as your >> pretext to present evidence
and you present evidence was a point. >> If by the way,
if he hadn't presented evidence, if he hadn't gone, look, this
is her trying to dox my my friend or whatever. If he hadn't presented
evidence, I think people would have gone and looked and figured
out that, oh, that's probably true. But it was like he was trying
to lay out the argument. And he was because obviously he went
and tried to lay it out on his stream as >> and realize
that he had to add that information to make the argument
>> So, didn't expect a concession. Low bar, I guess. >> I
mean, to be fair, I just think he, you know,
had every had the screenshots that picked him off, basically.
uh as he was skimming through and just didn't
you assumed it to be a given that oh yeah, of course she's doing
this, you know.
>> Oh, I I see it the other way. I think um I actually
think he was following the thread. I think he was probably following
the thread quite closely with >> No. Yeah. No, I agree.
I agree with you on that. But I'm saying that when he goes to
make the post, when he's actually making this allegation, he's
just skimmed through and been like, "Oh, the these are like the
really bad ones which talking and hasn't really thought too much
about what he's proving."
Yeah, he's not cuz he knows that it's true. He's probably been
talking about it with a lot of other people and so he's got context
he's not realizing the audience doesn't have. He put the same
screenshot twice in the tweet. Yeah,
Nick, legitimately, I'd rather you engage with the call if you're
going to type in their chat and throw donations. I just don't
agree with the idea that that if you're you're speaking through
like multiple layers instead of outright declaring your issues
after you said stuff and not calling up.
I don't care respectfully. 63 viewers, it's 636. Yeah, it wasn't
63. What the I didn't have 63 viewers. What the
the hell, man?
Fine. I'm never interacting with these people again. Wait, what
streams are we checking out? JT Auggie is on. This is the one.
JT kick stream. Don't forget it. Sorry, Snip, for the
Sadly, he has no Is this about Chud. Who is this about?
That looks good. You could totally pull it off. Nope, that's
somebody else.
Okay. Yo. Hey, we're watching you guys.
Look, look. They're watching. They're watching us. Go over them.
>> I'm going to close it before before that gets abused
in some way. Exact time stamp is 2 hours 15. Okay. Publicly,
she's on >> 2 hours 1550.
Now, what are the odds that he doesn't go, I didn't realize this
was necessary or something here before he actually presents it.
I didn't realize that it was confusing for people. Just in case
you're like stupid and just in case you're like a glue eater.
Here's the I feel like um
H I'm going to look like an [__] now if he says this
seems like um some additional context I missed. I'm an like the
story >> Oh, my bad. I was wrapping up this video. Um it's
the middle of the night. I was wrapping up this video and I was
told that my testimony for the doxing thing wasn't good enough
because I didn't show this screenshot that like definitively
proves that uh said her name again. Tom's girlfriend was trying
to to dox the person I went to VidCon with. Uh, I just assumed
that most people, if they didn't agree, would just go and look
through this the Kiwi Farms post to find it. But instead, there
was like a coordinated effort to just call me a liar, which I
appreciate that there was seemingly seemingly
had to edit that in.
>> People have since uh conceded on. But yeah, no, I mean,
you could literally just look this up. I don't really know why
I had to provide any more than I already did. I think the evidence
I showed was more than enough. But yeah, >> it wasn't because
there was nothing about doxing in the evidence provided.
>> Um, there was I think there was one
>> Oh, wait. Did he he he had to have had the gorilla mode
tweet in there. No, >> there's no way he didn't have the
gorilla mode tweet that he showed on stream. There's no way.
Oh, did he not even have the gorilla mode tweet?
Oh, the
there's no way, right, that he didn't even have the gorilla mode
tweet there.
No, this is the additional stuff. Oh my
dude.
Yeah. Yeah, there's literally nothing about doxing.
There's literally you looked deranged
objectively and you're trying to By the way, he is trying to
lay out I think I think even with the gorilla mode screenshot,
you can actually go back and say like, okay, I don't know. She's
saying I'm going gorilla mode. But she Oh, no. That maybe that
is the one.
I'm trying to remember how I I saw it at that point. There's
like there was a tweet that I saw or a picture that I saw a comment
where I had to go back even from that one and look again.
>> But I can't remember that one. >> I think it was
the gorilla motor. Go back and look because it's about it's then
it's a question of um who's the object and the um >> Oh,
right. No. Yeah, exactly.
By giving us this girl's name, you'll likely destroy any right.
We don't know if it's the VidCon girl at this point. This doesn't
prove it actually because or sorry, the um >> well that
that does show the docks in some way. Like seems like she had
the intent to do >> but it doesn't it does not necessarily
show that she had the intense dox girlfriend. But yeah, >> I
Yes. I think what No, no, no. I don't even think this is intented.
I think how I read this based on the messages before it was she
was really mad that she got cheated on. She was looking for the
name of the person who she got cheated on with and she was going
to publish that name and assuming it was like a content creator,
right? Cuz somebody said it was like a Destiny adjacent.
>> Oh, right. Maybe. Yeah.
>> So,
I do think
Yeah, I do think that that's true
that it was probably somebody like that. Um, and I I thought
that that's what she was going to do. I thought that was the
object here. And the idea that it would destroy the goodwill.
Cuz to me, I feel like you don't destroy any goodwill Nick has
for Tom if you publish if you like dox Nicholas Dioro's girlfriend.
That doesn't make any sense. What makes sense to me is if Tom
revealed to Nick that he was like somebody and Nick told his
friend who told other people, then that would destroy goodwill.
>> Obviously doesn't make a whole lot of sense. It's just
some KFer trying to lead down path to these guys. But yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So that that's why I was like, "Oh, I I don't think
that necessarily proves it."
But good times in any case.
Yeah, he didn't show what she was replying to. And when they
go up from this, this Gatorade's guy is saying, "No, you should
dox Nicholas Doro's girlfriend, but only do this if you want
to burn like all goodwill with people on the internet."
Yeah. So, this guy was he was trying to goat her into it, but
she needed one more message, which is in fact, I do think I think
you Jesus.
I think you I do think you actually Oh, right here. Yeah. So,
once you show this post without just the quote, then it's Yeah,
I don't know who she is. She does. She told me the girl was apparently
a long-term girlfriend. He's known since elementary school. I
asked her who she is just now.
Right. Well, I'm not going to hit the gas on the blood list here.
I think it's very fair to make clear by giving us this girl's
name. You likely So, that's where it becomes clear who the object
is. >> Yes. Okay. All right. Got it. Here. This is uh this
is more proof for the thing that was extremely obvious when I
said it on screen.
>> Yeah. Boom.
If it was extremely obvious, why add it at the end? I don't even
>> My whole chat agrees with me, dude. How could How, Dude,
my whole chat agrees with me. Literally, my whole chat. They
>> They all got it. They all seem to get it pretty easily,
guys. They all seem to get it. You guys not get it?